hello there this is steve kaufman here
and start out my sound file as well hi
it said we're getting close to Christmas
here although in Vancouver we don't get
snow at least not in the city it's
there's a great pile of snow up on
cypress mountain behind us but I just
want to have a little chat here I
haven't done a podcast in a while that
the linguist on language I changed a
look at the site want to make it more
fun I think language learning is a bug
fun and recently i posted some things
about a little exchange i had with the
American Center for Applied linguistics
and so there's a lot of material there
to read for people who want to read and
follow this little exchange or work on
their English or whatever and I thought
I would talk a little about it here
first of all I think I should admit that
I'm probably not a very nice person I'm
gonna clean my glasses a bit here I mean
at school seems to me I was always out
in the hall I had trouble with teachers
I always have trouble with teachers at
trouble of teachers just cleaning my
glasses that's what that noises because
i'm going to read no I tell the teachers
when they want to teach things at you
they want you to conform to their way
they want the pleasure of a feeling that
they have they have pushed some
knowledge at you the best teachers are
the ones that encourage you that inspire
you that that get on your side that make
things fun for you that are enthusiastic
those are the good teachers and but
unfortunately the teachers I don't know
if it's the kind of person who goes into
teaching but they want to take what is
basically a simple coaching situation
and converted into something where
things get codified you know learners
get classified by type by level by this
and the more complicated the
classification the better I mean here in
canada we have a thing called the bench
canadian language benchmarks it's got 12
of complex levels that nobody can
understand i can understand i'm a native
speaker obviously beginner intermediate
and advanced is to me good enough if you
need to classify people and i think a
lot of this rubs off on the learners
they think they need to constantly if
you told whether they are upper
intermediate or lower intermediate to
this and that and really it doesn't
matter how comfortable are you in the
language so a lot of this pedantry and
old for excessive complications
classification i think is very it's very
destructive because it takes away from
the fun of discovering the language but
getting back to my discussion with the
American Center for Applied linguistics
you know I had asked them I have been
participating on a forum for months and
months and months giving comments as
these teachers talk about what they
should do in the class should i have
people read to each other or not read to
each other and and of course the idea
especially they were talking about turf
non-english speakers who can hardly read
in their own language so getting these
people to read in a classroom in front
of others is is something that I just do
not understand it must be extremely
painful for the person for us to do it
and equally painful for the other people
who have to listen to it and of course
not very beneficial to their language
learning in my opinion and I personally
feel that a system like link where they
can go and on their own time they can
listen to their mp3 players over and
over again they can read on the computer
save words and phrases build up the
confidence to where they might be able
to read I think that's better at any
rate I asked these Council of this
American Council of applied linguistics
to look at link and nothing happened for
two and a half months so finally I get a
letter from a person there now
admittedly we had had an exchange
because I was upset about their
hypocritical anti commercial bias where
they wouldn't let me mention the
linguist as a source of lots of you know
over 2,000 items of audio and text for
people to use in their classrooms it's
free of tariffs go there and use it nope
can't mention that but so I get this
letter
and it is this letter is which I put up
on my blog it's so long-winded so
confusing this writer the doctor
somebody or other he begins by talking
about these fine distinctions of where
they get funding he mentions names ovae
I mean how am I supposed to know what o
v AE is and you know as a matter of both
academic definition and real-world
difference in brackets the differences
are significant requiring very different
it approaches just a whole lot of
pedantry and in the end he obviously
didn't look at at link because he
doesn't seem to understand what's there
he thinks it's got bilingual texts for
example which it doesn't have and and he
basically says you don't have and this
is basically to boil it all down into a
nutshell I won't read through this
because it's so poorly written that this
person quite honestly who wrote this
letter doctor whatever his name is Micah
say his name I mean he shouldn't be in
the English language teaching business
because he can't write English and
anyone who wants to read that text on my
blog and look at it and see how
confusing how disjointed how poorly
written this letter is why is this man a
doctor involved in language teaching but
my main peeve with these people comes
down to two points number one this we
are not for profit you are fee based
your got a personal interest we don't
that is nonsense the Center for Applied
linguistics is part of this whole cabal
of people that are out there saying you
know forty percent of the population
can't read it's costing the economy
billions of dollars it's a disaster give
us money and people do hey that sounds
pretty bad lots of people can't read so
they collect billions of dollars and of
course it's very fashionable starbucks
and i don't know who else is all in this
literacy thing we're going to help poor
people who can't read very well so they
can read better and get a better job
yeah at a certain level but the
organisation is like cow on their
website even the forums that they run
what is it for it's to promote their
name why do they want to promote their
name so they can grow as an organization
so that they can get
funding for the different activities so
their motivation is no different from
the motivation of a private company that
is offering a service the difference is
that their method of raising money and
generating income is to lobby people
tell big stories whereas a private
company their method is to try to get
users to see value in their product or
their service that's the only difference
and so ultimately something like this
not-for-profit organization is paid for
by the taxpayer by the private sector
which pays taxes and whose employees pay
taxes whereas a private company actually
has to survive on their own that's
number one and that is a major pet peeve
with me this whole and commercial you
mustn't mention this name or that name
whereas if they have an opportunity to
put a Coke machine in their school coke
dispensing machine to make money because
they get thirty percent take in goes the
coke machine and regardless of the
effects on the health of third of their
students and the second peeve I have is
you know if you don't have a degree in
language teaching tehsil teeths or
whatever and you can't talk about supra
segmental and and bilabial nasal
alveolar retroflex stop and all the
other garbage if you can't talk in their
jargon and if you don't have a degree in
there pedantic discipline they won't
even look at you and so that in the last
five or six years in the development of
link every time we've tried to go to
government to say here's something
that's good for immigrants can't be not
harmful it's just listening and reading
and learning words and it's free can we
do a pilot no you have to go to this
establish that whatever thing and find
out if it meets this criteria in that
criteria and do you have anyone on staff
who has a degree and this that and the
other and so forth so just try it on
some people see if they like it we have
lots of people around the world who are
using it and like it why not tied with
your group well have you done your solid
research as they do the Regis give it to
them is free so 2 p's one the anti
commercial bias we live in a commercial
world we are not in the we are not in
the a barter economy it makes sense that
agency or organization
a provides a service then they get money
for and then they give that to their
employees their employees go out and
spend money and what they want to spend
it works very well the money economy
works very well so don't constantly
knock profit and money and the the
parasitic sector of the economy which is
a not-for-profit government sector
should realize where their income comes
from and the second issue is be a little
more open-minded about different
approaches different solutions to
problems recognize that most of the
people who learn languages well do so on
their own because they are motivated
because they will find resources
wherever they are some of them may be
happy in a classroom a majority will do
it other in other ways watching movies
reading books you name it getting my
making friends and so forth so basically
that's partly what was behind you know
the sort of accumulated years of
frustration with the pedantic
protectionist education establishment is
largely what was behind this this
exchange and I guess the sort of
frustration that I felt on that I
expressed so there you have it that's my
little take and I'm going to stop it
right